in 1999 Darth Maul took the world by
storm with his brief appearance in Star
Wars The Phantom Menace though the
movies not really well loved by fans
today if there's one good thing that
came out of the first Star Wars prequel
it's Darth Maul too bad he died at the
end of the movie or did he
dungeon turns out getting chopped in
half and thrown down an elevator shaft
isn't quite the death sentence it used
to be
he is the untold truth of Darth Maul
planets of the rankles remember the
rancor the toothy drooly monster that
almost ate Luke Skywalker in Return of
the Jedi turns out that thing was from
the planet Dathomir
just like Darth Maul along with a clan
of force wielding which is called the
Nightsisters the animated Clone Wars TV
show spells out the details of Moore's
upbringing like the fact that he was
born to a High Priestess of the
Nightsisters grew up practicing force
magic and received a series of tattoos
all over his body some better than
others a forceful family during his
early life on Dathomir maul had two
brothers Ferrell and Savage Opress
after Maul left his home world of Darth
Sidious both feral and Savage Opress
continued their training following in
the traditions of their tribe eventually
Opress was chosen as a Sith apprentice
by the evil asajj ventress
one of the main villains from the Clone
Wars animated series and how did
Ventress test depresses loyalty by
commanding him to kill his brother feral
him
now if you think that tests bad don't
even ask about the written exam
half-life when it comes to lightsaber
fights there are cool mysterious ways to
die and then there's stuff more getting
cut in half
but it's hard to keep a good villain
down despite being sliced into Darth
Maul survived his duel with obi-wan
Kenobi moles tale of survival is
detailed in the Clone Wars based comic
book the chef hunters using the same
kind of hate-filled force power that
kept our Vader alive after getting
carved up by obi-wan Darth Maul's angry
tub half made his way to a garbage
planet called lotho-minor there he went
crazy became obsessed with taking
revenge on obi-wan oh and he figured out
how to make a new set of robot spider
legs like you do eventually moles little
brother Savage Opress rescued him from
lotho-minor and brought him back home
they're Moore's mommy helped him find
his lost marbles and even get a new pair
of legs magic legs
fun fact Darth Maul's original legs
figured out how to make a new robot
torso and has been washing dishes in
Dexter jettster diner
ever since Revenge of the Sith while
raising hell around the galaxy Darth
Maul and Savage Opress decided to go
after not just obi-wan Kenobi but also
Moore's former master Darth Sidious
better known as Senator Palpatine it
didn't go super well for more though
Sidious managed to defeat the brothers
killing Savage Opress and imprisoning
more for a time we would have guessed
like confronting an all-powerful master
of the dark side of the force who
single-handedly engineered a galactic
civil war and would become the future
emperor of evil space magic wouldn't be
a great idea Jedi trainer while the
Clone Wars TV series may have ended the
story was picked up again by the show
Star Wars rebels that show follows The
Adventures of a group of freedom
fighters including the Jedi and Padawan
pair of kanan jarrus and Ezra Bridger
and it was during season two that young
Ezra encountered Darth Maul who taught
him the ways of the dark side
fortunately for the fledgling rebellion
movement moles training didn't quite
stick and Ezra was still a good guy for
now man of few words so now you know all
about Darth Maul before and after his
debut in the Phantom Menace what you may
not know however is that he's actually
barely in that movie at all with roughly
15 minutes of total screen time and
while his epic lightsaber duel with
obi-wan Kenobi and qui-gon jinn accounts
for a good chunk of that he still only
uttered three actual lines of dialogue
now for your viewing pleasure here are
all the lines spoken by one of them
legendary movie villains to get cut in
half Tatooine sparsely-populated if the
trace was correct I will find them
quickly master at last we will reveal
ourselves to the Jedi at last we will
have revenge yes my master needless to
say the end result didn't really sit
well with Peter Serafinowicz the British
actor comedian who was tapped to give
more his voice interestingly he saw
signs that maybe this role wasn't all it
was cracked up to be
when he first went into record Moore's
voice and shared the recording booth
with George Lucas himself I said how do
you want me to do this what what
direction can you give me and he said
just make him evil you sound evil
alright Darth moly when it comes to
females let's just say the first six
Star Wars movies didn't really well have
many of them a couple of princesses a
shape-shifting bounty hunter with no
backstory and a handful of aliens are
just about the only women to show up in
George Lucas's Star Wars movies which
makes it all the more interesting to
learn that there were briefly plans to
make Darth Maul a woman in the early
days of pre-production for the Phantom
Menace George Lucas reportedly explained
that Darth Maul would be a figure from
your worst nightmare so concept artist
Ian McKay drew just that an evil looking
Sith which streaked with bloody looking
ribbons the concept evolved into darth
maul from there but the makers of the
Clone Wars television show reportedly
referred back to McCabe's original sit
the which design for the creation of
mores mother Talzin darth maul's future
it's hard to imagine that more than a
decade after he met his apparent demise
in the Phantom Menace that would have
this much daffy more to enjoy but his
resurrection in the pages of Star Wars
comics and has continued relevant on the
small screen means that this might still
be just the beginning for all things
more of Star Wars rebels continuing to
feature the horny hateful sis Lord
there's no telling where he might show
up next
Kedar more put in an appearance in Star
Wars Episode 8 or 9 and a spin-off movie
starring Han Solo and Lando Calrissian
on the horizon could we see a Darth Maul
solo film sometime in the not so distant
future it's hard to say now but one
thing is clear this is Harley the last
we've seen of one of Star Wars most
intimidating enduring and enigmatic
villains ever
what's up we easy thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel and watch more
videos like the one you just saw and
don't forget to check out all this cool
stuff we know that your love to